[Música]
[Aplausos]
a frost ya inicio en el año 2015 junto a
su vecino de 84 años a limpiar una playa
de ver soja en india al ver el
desinterés de las autoridades y de la
comunidad iniciaron ellos mismos
solamente ellos dos levantando una pieza
de basura a la vez afro se está
convencido que el amor es lo que mueve
al ser humano a tener una experiencia de
vida más auténtica y nos invita a tomar
acción porque el cambio viene con acción
no con las palabras con esto ha logrado
incentivar a muchos voluntarios a unirse
a esta iniciativa
esta actividad colectiva ha logrado que
los voluntarios logren recoger a
aproximadamente 13 millones de
kilogramos de basura hasta la fecha a
frost ya un joven abogado de mumbai es
sinónimo del proyecto de limpieza de
playas más grande del mundo todos los
fines de semana más voluntarios se unen
estudiantes turistas políticos hasta
actores de bollywood no solamente han
logrado mejorar la estética de esta
playa para que las personas puedan
volver a caminar sobre la arena y no
sobre la basura también esto ha
permitido el nacimiento de un gran
número de tortugas un fenómeno que no
ocurrirá en verso va desde hace más de
20 años a eso yo le llamo una onda
expansiva según la real academia
española una onda es cada una de las
elevaciones que se forman al perturbar
la superficie de un líquido
qué tengo que hacer yo para crear una
onda expansiva
que perturbe mi presente para crear un
futuro más humano más solidario con una
experiencia de vida más auténtica para
esto es importante reflexionar cómo es
mi presente
todos tenemos una rutina distinta pero
estoy segura que podemos coincidir en
algunos aspectos
pasamos horas en el tráfico de la casa
al trabajo a la universidad a la escuela
ser chofer de los hijos o de algún otro
familiar o pasar horas en el transporte
público poco eficiente invertimos tiempo
en trabajar en dormir en estudiar en
comer saludable en hacer ejercicio en
tener una vida social vida familiar en
fin
al final del día estamos cumpliendo al
culpando al tiempo de no tener
suficientes horas para hacer todo lo que
quiero hacer
y es que al final soy yo quien decide
qué es lo que voy a hacer en mi presente
soy yo la responsable
hay mucha información en internet
tutoriales que nos enseñan cómo manejar
nuestro tiempo clave para sobrevivir la
rutina 10 tips para despertarse temprano
33 hacks para personas altamente
creativas y mucha información que nos
llega a nuestro correo electrónico y a
nuestras redes sociales también los
consejos que nos dan las personas que
conocemos
aprendemos técnicas con las nuevas
tecnologías que tenemos ahora como por
ejemplo organizar nuestro calendario
como por bloques si aun ustedes no lo
han intentado se los recomiendo a manera
de autoanálisis puede ser muy revelador
especialmente si a esto le agregas las
estadísticas que te da tu teléfono de
cuánto tiempo pasas en cada aplicación
que has descargado
entonces en que pienso cuando alguien me
pregunta o en qué piensan ustedes cuando
alguien les pregunta que si quieren
formar parte de una actividad de
voluntariado
no tengo tiempo no tengo dinero y
entonces como le doy a esa otra persona
eso que yo no tengo
en mi camino a encontrar una mayor
productividad mi novio me dio el mejor
consejo
si quisieras tener más tiempo podrías
probar tener menos cosas
así tendrían menos cosas que limpiar y
que ordenar
bueno esta idea detonó un sinfín de
estudios acerca del minimalismo primero
para ahorrar tiempo pero también para
ahorrar dinero el minimalismo tiene una
premisa que es tener solo aquello que le
aporta valor a tu vida como elijo eso
que es tan importante y que le aporta
valor a mi vida
stanislaw 4 chile es un psicólogo de
república checa y en 1968 publicó un
estudio acerca del sentido de la vida y
la orientación de los valores de las
personas
este estudio divide a las personas en
dos grupos
en el primer grupo las personas y
asignan una igual importancia a todos
sus valores
le pueden dar mucha importante
importancia a su trabajo también a su
familia pueden tener tiempo para un
hobby o dos también se preocupan por su
crecimiento espiritual y por su salud
física todo esto constituye una base que
les hace sentir feliz y satisfactorios
el segundo grupo de personas le dan más
importancia a un valor y construyen su
sentido de vida como una pirámide
colocando ese valor más importante en la
parte de arriba
pero qué es lo que pasa cuando a esta
persona le llega una carta diciendo que
en su trabajo está pasando por una
reestructuración y que su puesto de
trabajo ya no existe ese valor que es el
trabajo que era el que más importancia
le daba a esta persona se derrumba
porque la base de la pirámide no tiene
fuerza
yo era parte de este segundo grupo hace
algunos años
después del fallecimiento de mi padre
todos hemos bienvenida
y el teléfono de la esperanza a
solicitar ayuda buscando tener control
sobre mi vida
en cambio encontré un grupo de personas
que me ayudó a entender que los valores
los valores cambian todo el tiempo
que la vida cambia todos los días
y me ayuda a encontrar el equilibrio
fue con este grupo de personas que viven
entendí el valor de las ondas expansivas
porque el voluntariado
es un proceso de sanación que inicia
desde el núcleo desde nuestro y desde
nuestro interior expandiéndose a nuestra
familia a la comunidad y a la humanidad
entera
la solidaridad es una parte inherente
del ser humano
en 14 años de servicio gratuito de
intervención en crisis los voluntarios
del teléfono de la esperanza han estado
en servicio escuchando a otras personas
por más de 500 mil horas recibiendo un
aproximado de 717 mil 500 llamadas y el
40% de estas personas
dicen de que tienen problemas familiares
o relacionales
es el voluntariado
una de las formas para producir ondas
expansivas porque también motiva a otras
personas a unirse e impulsa
transformaciones sociales
en mi presente en este momento yo estoy
consciente y me siento feliz tranquila y
en paz porque soy yo quien decido y aún
sabiendo que no tengo el control de todo
yo sé de que ahorita soy yo quien toma
las decisiones
todos podemos tener un presente
consciente o inconsciente y les invito a
que quieran formar parte de algo más
grande
que lo lleve a ser más humanos más
solidarios aprender a escuchar a tener
empatía a tener una experiencia de vida
más auténtica
y eso lo vamos a tratar de hacer hoy
vamos a tratar de probar ese poder de
las ondas expansivas y voy a necesitar
la ayuda de ustedes me imagino que en
algún momento han estado en un estadio
deportivo o han visto un encuentro
deportivo por la por la televisión
y saben lo que es una ola verdad
una bala como esta
bueno hace un rato ya les hicieron hacer
un ejercicio porque toda la mañana
tienen de estar aquí escuchando
activamente a los speakers que han
estado en el escenario pero ahora sí les
voy a pedir que se levanten de sus
asientos
que nos estiramos y levantemos los
brazos tratando de alcanzar el cielo del
auditorio
y respiren
tomemos acción muy bien excelente muchas
gracias pueden sentarse de nuevo
ahora
vamos a iniciar la ola desde el lado
izquierdo del auditorio hacia el lado de
derecho
y como siempre a la cuenta de tres
vamos a iniciar listos por aquí 1 2 3 2
eso está muy bien felicidades
solo se necesita tomar acción para
iniciar ondas expansivas gracias
[Aplausos]